-Welcome to the show.
-Well, thank you, Seth.
-I want to tick off some thing
that are impressive about you.
You're one of the most popular
governors in America,
you are a Republican in
a blue state,
and you have been
vocally critical
of the president.
Why are there not more of you?
-Wow.
Well, that's a good question
You know, I'm kind of
one in a million, Seth.
I mean, you know...
I think that there probably ar
some other folks out there
that are like me, but they don't
get a lot of attention.
So, look, like most people
in America,
I'm completely fed up with all
this divisive, angry politics,
and I think that --
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, so, I'm in a state that
has 26% Republican.
Just got overwhelmingly
re-elected as a Republican
70% of my legislature
is Democrats.
Because I've worked toward
the middle
and tried to find
that common ground,
where we can all stand together.
And I just happen to believe
that there's a whole lot mor
that unites us than divides us
and we should do away
with all the angry politics.
-You are --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You just became chair of the
National Governors Association
This is a bipartisan group
of all our governors.
-I'm pretty sure that's
the first time
they've ever mentioned the
National Governors Association
on late-night television.
-Yeah. It has not come up, yeah.
You maybe noticed the slow way
I said it
to make sure I got it right.
You are a part of a group called
the...National --
-National Governors Association.
-Yeah.
Tell me, though -- This does not
look like you're dancing with --
That's -- Is that Marie Osmond
-That is Marie.
Yeah, it was last --
-So, here, everybody thought
"Oh, National Governors
Association --
that sounds super-boring,"
but there you are
rockin' it out.
-Well, so, last Friday,
I just became the chairman
and they had
a little event afterwards.
Donnie and Marie put on a show
and she dragged me up on
the stage and embarrassed me
And, look, I'm hoping I can ge
a Nutrisystem gig out of it.
-Yeah, I was going to say.
You are a Republican who
believes in climate change
You believe that's
a very serious issue.
You also -- Which is great
You also believe
in infrastructure.
Do you feel as though
infrastructure can lead to
helping eradicate
climate change?
I know, for example, you have --
in your state,
you have moved more money
towards highway infrastructure
as opposed to
public transportation.
That seems maybe
counterintuitive
to somebody who believes climate
change is such a big deal.
-Not really true,
but thanks for saying that
-Which -- Well, there was a --
I mean, I don't want to get into
transportation.
-So, we've invested $14 billio
in transit,
about $9 billion in roads.
We've just moved forward.
We're under construction
with the largest
public-private transit project
in North America.
And I pushed through tougher
clean-air standards
than 48 other states and twice
as strong as the Paris Accords
as a Republican governor
in Maryland.
-And do you feel as though
you are --
And I genuinely think
that's great news.
Do you feel as though you're
making progress
with the other governors?
Because it seems to me -- Yo
basically wrote an op-ed sayin
that, yes, federally, right now,
Donald Trump is moving awa
from the Paris Climate Accords
but you believe, state by state,
this can be addressed.
-Look, so we have
a group called RGGI,
which is the Regional
Greenhouse Gas Initiative.
We had nine states.
We now have 13 states
on the East Coast
that are all together.
And I think we are
making a difference.
Some states are taking it more
seriously than others,
but my new role as chairman of
the National Governors
Association --
I'm representing Democrati
and Republican governors,
and I can tell you that people
are focused on the issue
and taking it seriously.
And one of the great thing
about this organization is -
it's a really bipartisan,
nonpartisan group
on infrastructure,
which I just launched
my initiative last week.
There's disagreement
among Republicans and Democrat
about how to
solve these problems,
but we're actually getting
things done in the states,
unlike Washington,
where it seems like we hav
nothing but divisiveness,
and dysfunction and gridlock
You know,
we're getting things done.
That's what people want.
-Which is great,
and I'm really glad.
And, again, I think it is
the issue of this generation
so I'm really happy that
you are taking it seriously.